[Musique]
il ya quelques années lors de mes
explorations de journalistes j'ai
entendu parler d'un peuple qui vit au
nord de la colombie et qui disait
travailler à maintenir l'équilibré du
monde
rien que ça en fait ils écoutaient la
terre la nature pour savoir quelle
action entreprendre quoi planter quand
récoltés comment mieux vivre ensemble
pratique et les rituels se soigner
s'éduquer
bref prendre soin de la vie étrangement
cette idée d'un équilibre du monde a
résonné en moi comme un écho ça m'a
donné comme un frisson dans le dos je me
suis dit et si c'était vrai est ce qu'il
nous raconte ça m'a donné comme un élan
une envie de comprendre de d'emprunter
leur regard sur le monde pour le voir
autrement
et depuis cette langue n'a plus vraiment
quitté ce qui est fou c'est qu'à partir
du moment où j'ai eu ce frisson j'ai
rencontré des personnes qui étaient en
lien avec d'autres peuples racines comme
on les appelle
est ce réellement racontait faisait
aussi pour moi alors qu'est ce que ces
peuples qui vivent dans les cultures
toutes autres parfois dans un inconfort
un dénuement total venus touchée en moi
femme blanche un peu perdu au milieu de
notre modernité matérialiste et opulente
pour le comprendre suis allé interroger
ces personnes que j'appelle des
passeuses et des passeurs et qui avait
vécu longuement auprès d'eux pour tous
ceux là avaient complètement transformé
leur vie et surtout leur regard sur la
vie et c'est aussi ce qui s'est passé
pour moi en côtoyant ces passeurs et en
vivant avec eux des expériences inspiré
de ses cultures à l'ue mais nos français
strahl sans allumettes écouter des
histoires autour du feu vivre des
rituels issus de ces peuples qu'ils
soient navarro d'arizona masaï du kenya
glee de colombie lakota des grandes
plaines ou bien encore d'amazonie
ou de sibérie et peu à peu à travers ses
expériences et bien j'ai réalisé que ma
mission et elle a rassemblé ce que
j'avais perçu de ce que nous avons tous
en commun ou doux que nous soyons aux
quatre coins de la planète et ce commun
et bien c'est notre intériorité ou
encore larmes humaine est ce que ces
peuples ont depuis toujours conservé qui
m'attend touchés et bien c'est une
connaissance profonde de cette
intériorité et surtout des liens qui
l'unissent au monde
c'est ainsi que je suis devenu une
exploratrice de ce qui nous relie une
passeuse de ces liens qui sont
universelles et finalement pour cela je
n'ai pas eu besoin d'aller au bout du
monde
parce que ce qui nous relie c'est
d'abord en nous mêmes et c'est d'abord
en moi même que je suis allé le
rencontrer
en réalité mon parcours me avait un peu
préparé par chance je suis né j'ai
grandi dans une magnifique région de
nature ici en france qui s'appelle la
brenne grandir dans cet espace sauvage a
nourri en moi la conscience du trésor
que j'avais sous les yeux j'ai vite
compris que nos modes de vie
technologique l'agressait que la course
à la croissance ou toujours plus et est
tout sauf un modèle d'équilibré
parce que ce besoin de chercher un sens
à tout ça m'évitait déjà j'avais choisi
le métier de journaliste je suis allé
travailler dans une grande ville paris
mais dans ce mode de vie urbain j'étais
plus tout à fait en cohérence avec ce
que j'avais eu la chance de vivre
lorsque lorsque j'étais enfant j'étais
donc en plein questionnement celui du
milieu de vie comme on l'appelle
quand j'ai vu ce fameux frisson qui m'a
amené à m'intéresser à ces passeurs et à
ses peuples et on les interrogeait en
recoupant les informations
j'ai donc découvert qu'au delà de leurs
différences culturelles leur sagesse
était universel et surtout elle
répondait à toutes ces questions de sens
que je me posais depuis longtemps donc
je me suis mise à les rassembler langue
dans mes livres de façon à mettre en
lumière ce qui pouvait nous aidez nous à
retrouver un peu plus d'équilibré en
réalité dans le monde vivent tout à une
place un rôle une fonction et c'est
parce que chaque élément est à sa place
que la vie tient en équilibre dans la
longue des lakotas il y à un monde qui
veut dire à la fois santé et vie cwi
tshosane et oui tshosane ici je le
traduis littéralement ça donne un homme
en équilibre à l'intérieur autrement dit
pour être en santé et en vie il s'agit
d'être en équilibre à l'intérieur alors
c'est pas juste un équilibre qui permet
de se sentir bien à l'intérieur de soi
imaginez plutôt des cercles qui
s'imbriquent le serbe de la personne
elle même celui du clan de la nation du
monde en général c'est parce qu'il y
aura une harmonie dans chacun de ces
cercles et entre chacun de ces cercles
que l' équilibre pourra être trouvé
alors comment ils parviennent il est
bien en mettant au coeur de leurs
préoccupations
la qualité de la relation
relation avec soi relations avec les
autres en relation avec la nature et ce
n'est pas juste parce que ce serait bien
au moral d'être gentil avec les autres
ou parce que ils savent que la nature
ils en ont besoin mais parce qu'ils ont
cette conscience que la santé donc l'
équilibre en dépendent
pour eux le monde est comme un immense
organismes dont nous faisons partie et
notre santé en est le baromètre
donc si nous allons mal c'est que le
monde va mal et si nous prenons soin du
monde de la ville nous prenons soin de
nous et réciproquement
alors si je transpose cette logique
à l'exemple du coronavirus qu'est ce que
ça donne
à l'origine ce virus vivait dans un
milieu particulier on a parlé de poing
gaulin de vison de chauves-souris cissé
milieu étaient restés intacts là où ils
sont est ce que le virus serait parvenu
jusqu'aux humains
certainement pas c'est d'ailleurs ce que
relevait des chercheurs dans un rapport
de l'onu en octobre 2020 entre autres un
qui précisait que 70 % des maladies
virales émergentes proviennent de
pathogènes animaux et que la destruction
des milieux naturels est la cause
principale des pandémies
alors ces peuples en fait ils nous
disent exactement la même chose mais
d'une façon bien plus simple
tellement simple qu'on les croit parfois
naïve dans un écosystème en équilibre
chaque espèce chaque montagne chaque
ruisseau chaque rocher a sa raison
d'être
et si les plantes et les animaux vivent
spontanément ce pour quoi ils sont faits
eh bien les humains eux ont besoin de
chercher leur place dans le monde sont
quoi faute de la trouver ils apprennent
de force et il a service
nature chacun d'entre nous a donc un
chemin à faire pour retrouver ce
pourquoi nous sommes là et celle
avantages de cette vision elle
sous-entend que rien ni personne ne
vient dans la vie par hasard que nous
avons tous chacun une raison d'être
comme un talent particulier qui nous
permet à la fois nous épanouir et de
contribuer à l'équilibré
cette vision là je les retrouve et on et
sagesse de tous les peuples sur lesquels
je me suis penché il l'appelle médecine
personnel mission de vie puissance
parfois même pouvoir
mais attention ce n'est pas un pouvoir
qu'on va exercer sur les autres ou sur
le monde sans quoi attention au retour
de bâton
c'est un pouvoir sur soi même une
capacité à savoir qui en est et donc à
créer une relation équilibrée avec ceux
qui nous entourent et pour y parvenir il
existe un langage nous avons oublié
c'est celui du vivant nous pouvons
réapprendre ce langage nous remettre à
l'ecoute nous laisser enseigner par les
plantes les animaux la nature en général
c'est pour cela que ces peuples méritent
leur nom de peuples racines et c'est un
peu aussi leur recette du bonheur
ils lisent la nature la terre comme un
grand livre à travers lequel
l'intelligence de la vie leur parle et
les aide à savoir qui ils sont et nous
mais nous si elle nous parle en fait et
c'est à nous de réapprendre de nous
remettre à écouter pour retrouver notre
place harmonieuse dans le vivant pour
retrouver notre pouvoir et pour
redevenir nous aussi un peuple ration
comment
et bien pour vous en faire goûter la
saveur
je vous propose de vous inviter dans un
petit voyage imaginaire
si vous le voulez bien fermer les yeux
ouvrons la porte et glissons nous dans
la forêt la plus proche de chez vous
avant d'entrer prenons le temps
d'observer considérer les arbres et ses
milliers d'êtres qui l'a pas plomb ils
vont vous laisser entrer sur leur
territoire inspiré une bonne bouffée de
l'air pur qu'il vous offre
et puis à les y glisser vous entrez dans
ce royaume sauvage ralentissez le pas
ouvrez grandes vos oreilles
qu'entendez-vous le chant des oiseaux
des feuilles du vent imaginez que tous
ces sons vous parle il vous raconte une
histoire quelque chose de leur vie que
vous ne voyez pas ne cherchez pas à
comprendre imprégnez-vous comme d'une
langue étrangère qu'un jour peut-être
vous parlerez
et puissante et les parfums de la forêt
l'odeur chaude des pins ou bien
l'humidité de la terre des feuilles des
mousses tiens qu'est-ce que ça fait sa
une mousse fraîche et douce sur la peau
sous les pieds ça vous fait envie
retirez vos chaussures posez vos pieds
nus sur le sol sur la terre sur les
feuilles sur les mousses et laissez-vous
ressentir à travers tous vos sens avec
tout votre corps avec tout votre coeur
et puis si l'envié vous en prend
allongez-vous dans l'herbe roulez vous
dans les feuilles marché dans les
flaques retrouver votre joie d'enfant
dans votre corps d'aujourd'hui
chantaient dansaient laissez vous aller
un endroit vous attire
prenez le temps asseyez vous observez
santé touchées
laissez vous toucher n'attendez rien
goûter vous avez aimé
et bien je vous propose de recommencer
chaque jour ou presque
en vrai et vous voyez comment la
relation se tissent entre vous et
seulement d'oublier santé ce que cela
vous fait à l'intérieur
comment ça vous change vous apaise et
peut-être même déjà parce que cela vous
apprends parce qu'au bout du compte
c'est une autre capacité de l'humain qui
s'éveillera en vous une capacité que
nous avons oublié dans notre course
contre le temps
c'est une intelligence à part entière
l'intelligence perceptive qui nous
permet de réentendre la symphonie du
monde
et elle nous aide aussi chacun a
retrouvé notre place dans la mystérieuse
chorégraphie du vivant au final c'est un
sacré voyage vers le coeur de soi même
et nous pouvons tous le faire sans avoir
à aller au bout du monde
parce que comme le disent si joliment si
justement les lakotas le monde est
déposé en nous alors poussons notre
porte intérieure
ouvrons notre sensibilité et devenons
des explorateurs de l'âme humaine qui
nous relient merci
[Musique]